Ще недавно друг Заходу, рукостискання і довірливі розмови…
А тепер він регулярно на допитах і в судах.
Обсяг кримінальних проваджень стосовно п'ятого президента України
не залишився поза увагою політиків у Німеччині.
Вони проводять прямі паралелі зі справою експрем’єрки Юлії Тимошенко,
кримінальне переслідування якої ініціювали за Віктора Януковича
після його перемоги на виборах у 2010 році.
Про паралелі зі справою Тимошенко каже і доповідач з питань України
у фракції канцлерки Меркель ХДС/ХСС Франк Штеффель.
За його словами, роздмухується будь-яка дрібниця,
аби відкрити на Порошенка якесь провадження.
Німецьких політиків дивує, що хоча на експрезидента заведено понад 20 справ,
підозри у корупції або зловживанні владою в інтересах бізнесу
щодо Порошенка не розслідують.
Боротися з корупцією треба.
А Порошенко, без сумніву, робив сумнівні речі у бізнесі.
Але те, що йому інкримінують нині, - це переважно речі,
пов'язані з перевищенням повноважень
або навіть якісь порушення митних процедур при ввезенні картин.
За кримінальним переслідуванням Петра Порошенка
уважно стежать і у зовнішньополітичному відомстві Німеччини.
Слід зазначити, що з початку президентства Володимира Зеленського
з Берліна Києву надходили переважно підбадьорюючі сигнали.
Тепер ситуація у відносинах, схоже, переживає зміну.
Як розповіли Deutsche Welle дипломатичні джерела,
на нещодавній зустрічі глави німецького МЗС Гайко Мааса з  Дмитром Кулебою
Берлін порушував тему боротьби з корупцією
та забезпечення норм правової держави
Зокрема, німецька влада спантеличена планами української влади
реформувати судочинство на свій лад,
ігноруючи рекомендації Венеціанської комісії Ради Європи.
А незаангажованість очільниці Офісу генпрокурора Ірини Венедіктової
викликає відверті сумніви депутатів Бундестагу.
У Берліні стурбовані подіями у Києві ще з іншої причини.
Боротьба з конкурентами не політичними засобами, а шляхом кримінальних переслідувань
завдає серйозної шкоди репутації країни, кажуть німецькі політики.
Вони також застерігають, що за кілька років Володимира Зеленського
в разі зміни влади так само можуть чекати кримінальні провадження.
Адже він, так само як і Порошенко, у перший рік президентства
не демонструє політичної волі для підсилення незалежності юстиції від політичних впливів.
Тому мій заклик до Зеленського - якщо він має вплив на правосуддя,
а такі побоювання, на жаль, існують, - подбати про те, аби його попередника
не атакували божевільними закидами, і усе робилося юридично чисто.
Занепокоєні справами проти Порошенка не лише у Німеччині.
Зокрема, Дональд Туск від імені Європейської народної партії зробив заяву
про неприпустимість вибіркового правосуддя.
І хоча ці події ще не дійшли до рівня, коли на них почнуть реагувати
керівники європейських держав,
ситуація загрожує затьмарити відносини України із Заходом,
коли Києву все ще потрібна його підтримка.